the main thing about this particular
jump is you have to get up to the
tallest mountain in the world you have
to get to the top and I don't know any
other wingsuit BASE jumper that has ever
done that I'm more nervous now here in
California working my way towards going
in Nepal then I will be when I'm
actually standing at base camp
everything about this setup is gonna be
different you know I won't have all this
parachute stuff and everything it'll be
you know much harsher conditions you
know to be minus 20-30 on the summit of
Everest I'm going to use this very
specific mechanism to jump off into land
something and that's never been seen
before technology and equipment that's
never been used this suit allows me a
lot more flexibility with my arms and
legs I'm actually gonna have to take a
running start so I have to make multiple
step all these vents and these suits and
the arms and the legs below the suit up
a lot bigger than what it looks like
here on the ground there's a place for
cameras here on the helmet i'll have
cameras so you'll see multiple live
camera positions in the side the suit
i'll also have like a best so we'll have
all the different labs transmitters and
batteries that a survival pack jumping
off your arms are up a bit more like
this and then they sort of get retract
the arms of it so coming from here down
to about here and then leaning forward
that speed generates in to lift it
allows me to fly out further than i'm
dropping down I don't like to use the
word superhero but you're I'm
essentially doing something that I
shouldn't be able to do I've done most
of the things I wanted to do this would
be you know kind of the the blasting cap
at the end kind of like Felix I say that
now but i'll probably end up in space to
its some point